do you have the the sort of cross wiring
associated associative type situation
where if you're playing doom as an
example and if like I call you and you
keep playing and I say I have the
craziest story to tell you and then a
year later if you replay that level will
that conversation the moment you hit
that part of the level will it trigger
for you because that has happened to me
my whole life I'll go back and replay a
game I haven't played in 10 years and
I'll like into a room and I'll suddenly
be like this was the moment that my
friend who I haven't spoken to in 7
years called me to say he got engaged or
something because I'll just it just
attaches to the visuals and the the
geography of that room permanently for
me it's a bizarre with and I've tweeted
about this before and and didn't see as
many people share the sentiment as I did
I have with music so when I play a game
and I'm listening to a certain album at
the same time they are just forever that
is an offensive premise to a story I
don't mean at the same time though like
you know you mean the music that was
composed for the game like if I'm
playing through resident evil 3 right
now and when I'm not playing the game
I'm also listening to Childish Gambino's
latest album which I am now for the rest
of my life I remembered this week as
Resident Evil 3 and childish gambino and
they are paired together rather than
like I'm not actually listening to that
music at the same time what if you were
also eating like pizza rolls at the same
time would you then associate because I
just do that every day there's less of
an association where pizza rolls are
concerned but there isn't the sense of
smell is the smarter or is the most
indelible memories memory it's attached
memory because the fact is the proximity
to the part of the the brain right I I
thought is bit right so it's the lowest
frequency it's the lowest complexity of
data
smell smell that's what that's why I
don't
believe that because I think humans have
a very bad sense of smell so things are
blanketed like humans can say subway
subway smells like subway but a dog
would smell a hundred different
ingredients whereas I just joined bredis
be very clear I don't know if this is
bollocks no no IIIi know you made made
subsurface circular so I'm sure this was
part of the research in there here's an
interesting fact someone I can remember
the source of this but they said that if
you could represent the entire spectrum
of light it would out on 35 millimeter
film it would stretch from LA to San
Francisco I think they said what we can
see as humans would fit on a single
frame so it's like the audacity for us
to say that whatever we just see is
obviously the be-all end-all of reality
clearly that's that's so not true Neil
deGrasse Tyson harps on about that and
especially if you watch like from 1015
years ago you know I had this kick where
maybe not quite that long ago maybe
eight or nine years ago I had a kick
where it's just every time I could find
a new sort of lecture or QA of his on on
YouTube I was just ravenously consuming
and he had a whole shtick about how you
know by measure of the full spectrum of
light were effectively blind there are
there are creatures just on earth you
know never mind what's theoretically
possible elsewhere
of seeing you know like we basically see
three colors and and that's it there's
things that can seem way more than that
and can see into the ultraviolet or can
see down into infrared right I think
that the colors we can see are generally
indicative of if I eat this thing it
might make me sick yeah supposed to be
the point if it's this color I shouldn't
eat it chorus I would imagine animals
that are prey it's a big thing with fish
if your prey you need to or sorry yes no
praise the right word if you need to be
aware of anything that looks like a
cookie too
and anything that looks like it should
be a threat to you which is probably a
much larger spectrum whereas we just
need to be oh that's a gun yeah so
because we're an apex predator we don't
really know actually so a perfect
well the I don't know if you would count
like a bird of prey is necessarily an
apex predator but probably within their
ecosystem like oh yeah like for real or
an eagle they I read that they again I
this might this might be wrong I'm
reasonably it was I think it was hawks
or Eagles or a similar like an osprey
what one it within that realm with a
they viciously destroy their prey what a
reductive ah they could see into the
ultraviolet spectrum because apparently
like the little voles and [ __ ] on the
ground when they urinate its it pops in
ultraviolet and it's partly how they see
from far away like a spotlight of like
there's a rat I just cuz it's almost
like a neon sign relative to everything
else on and I thought that's [ __ ]
interesting like that and it totally
explains why it's not that they have our
vision but just to this outrageous
degree of fidelity it's that they
actually see things we fundamentally can
we were at that that place in Ireland
that we go to and they may have a hawk
walk that you can do and they'll bring
the Falcons out and you can actually
they say thank you and ultraviolet yeah
if they it's funny because they said you
know do not raise your arm because if
you raise your arm even just just to
point at something if you go like well
over there is like that Hawk will come
to you and it'll sit on your arm and
it's very
when it does that so they said that
without the like armored gauntlets it'll
just rip your arm off
yeah and so the main thing that they do
is they they weigh them by grams before
you actually go out on the walk because
they know if they're up two or three
grams over they're gonna be fat and
they're not gonna be motivated to go do
anything so they wait this guy hasn't
had breakfast yes same exact just a few
friends I step on a scale even before
doing this but he said watch this and we
had no idea where the hawk was and he
just took like a like it was a frozen
Mouse or whatever it threw it up in the
air and that thing I have it in slow
motion video I go Shh and just swooped
in out of nowhere and grabbed that thing
but it's the exact same thing it's like
they see like that they're like predator
they can see everything they see blood
urine anything in like super high one
thing I've always very cool is that
humans can only create things that they
have for the most part seen before so
you know every dream that you have every
face that you see is a person that you
don't recognize but your brain is not
capable of inventing a face it has to
take features from other things you've
already seen we're not very good at just
imagining appearances of things so every
time anyone's ever tried to create an
alien it's not going to be anything like
what an alien looks like because we
can't even comprehend something being
visually different to other shapes or
objects we've already seen on earth
I don't like HR Giger or Geiger however
you say his name like that guy was
clearly seeing that's some Lovecraft I
think he might have had some inspiration
from the real world for those designs
titties and dicks everywhere that's
right it was always always Raynal it was
always anal with that there's there's if
in in Greer France is a the is a gig or
Geiger I've always heard
I will actively work out what the other
person is using and intentionally use
the other things just to mess with them
every
well in that case let's see if we can
let's see if we can break Mike then so
Troy you double down on Gieger I'm gonna
say Geiger and well there's there's a
museum in this like beautiful little
medieval Hamlet that is where the cheese
is from and the entire town smells like
Gruyere cheese or if you don't like
stinky cheese it's it's a quick stop for
you but there's this great little Museum
all about him and features a lot of the
conceptual art for alien and they're
like trying to desperately to get all
the non grier fans to stay for something
I guess but the cool like we need to put
all the best stuff stuff at one place it
gets super [ __ ] up real fast like I
had to go outside I was like man because
it's all just like satanic and oh yeah
and anal and everything but then across
from that instead of a gift shop there
is which there is a gift shop of course
but outside of of the museum is a alien
inspired themed bar that has like yeah
so like you can sit in like these big
chairs and it looks like you're
basically on the ship it's so it's my
shelf of props oh yes you do that we
could come up with just so that I went
to a cinema and the guy that I said I've
got a magic bookshelf and I says what
you know what's the curse he said it's a
great bookshelf so any book you want but
you will annoyingly bring them out as
props disappeared 15 minutes in we are
excellent
it still counts as an intro it's fine
I'm a lot of piece I am joined by video
game composer Austin wintery video game
at Detroit Baker and video game director
Mike Bissell how's everyone doing slash
librarian slash liberium director my
goodness you run your you run your
bookstore like a Harry Potter wand shop
it's John Hurt very good you should
consider a boy septic dabbling I keep
this a hobby maybe it's a hobby yeah so
I keep wanting to talk about this one
topic that today I'm just gonna Britt my
brute force my way into it and make us
actually talk about it before you get
into the book yeah Austin what's going
on with Osama water's edge yeah what
happened your face would you do your
face she hasn't figured out I did
anything yet so shut up happily not made
a Star Wars joke I have been watching
season two of climb walls how is in
treating me I really like too deep I I
yeah it's on the list I especially
knowing that they're they've just
wrapped it up right they've just or
they're in the midst of bringing it to a
major I'm not like super up-to-date on
this very stoic TV shows but I've second
hand launched a bunch of rebels and yeah
second season Columbus intersection
really good no I'm not no tangent
stopped I'm not doing it so I've been
meaning to ask you guys question that I
feel like is relevant to what maybe some
listeners are going through right now
which is any video games that have maybe
comforted you or gotten you through
difficult periods of time
because I feel like full disclosure I'm
on the board of a charity called
checkpoint which is entirely about
mental health and its relationship to
video games and I highly recommend you
check it out as a resource but I what is
it can you unpack actually well finish
but then will you circle back to that
because I want to know how that operates
like I'm very curious what the actual
that would be a tangent Austin no I know
I know I don't
it's fun it's they're the guys who
organized the quiet rooms bigger bonus
room correct
yeah I've been amazing I love those are
so useful people like me you go
overwhelmed yes
we also basically just like create
resources for exactly things like this
like exactly what's happening right now
which is basically things people can do
to maintain their mental health through
video games as an avenue and also like
have a lot of discussions on some stuff
that I found really interesting which is
just like how certain depictions of
things can have an effect on what you
see in the real world how playing a game
that gives you positive reinforcement
can make you feel accomplished if you're
a person with a disability you can't go
outside like things like that because
you know so much of modern media still
rejects the idea that video games have
those benefits when I think they
enormous ly do so I was going to jump
straight into my story which I have shed
on my channel before but basically and
this is why I chose the witness as a
background anyone who's watching the
video version when I first moves not
Firewatch
when I first moved to the US I didn't
have insurance for the first like three
months or so and I got sick and I got
pneumonia so that was in in a January I
actually got pneumonia I kind of blamed
CES I was already sick but then I went
to CES in Vegas which is the bane of my
existence is me just being in Vegas
generally I mean dice wiped me out this
year but basically that meant I was
still in the throes of major culture
shock which I think people don't quite
acknowledge when you move from a country
that has similar cultural values frankly
I'm still learning they're not that
similar but the same language culture
shock is still a massive thing when you
move countries no matter why I'm moving
to or from Australia to New Zealand
you'd still have culture shock but it's
also you know being really far away from
everyone I know I always say that is a
really big thing about me moving
countries when I was 21 was that I left
behind every human I had ever met
and that's such a weird thing to do in a
permanent sense so there's just a lot of
generally the first month of moving
somewhere new you're really excited the
second month you're still trying to
adjust and then the
third month is when most people do get
really miserable and that's exactly when
this happened to me was that I just
[ __ ] this time and the thing that was
keeping me saying was that I was going
to walk every day at IGN I was making
new friends they were all really
friendly and would invite me out all the
time and then boom I get pneumonia and
I'm told that I can't leave the house I
had the option to go to hospital and
stay in there for a period of time but
it was prohibitively expensive so yeah I
had this really bad cough I can't sleep
because the coughs so bad which I
imagine it's probably pretty similar
well anyone who has coronavirus is
experiencing and it is absolutely
miserable you can't speak very well you
have no energy it's just everything's in
pain and yours coughing all the time so
in this period where I was already
pretty miserable due to that culture
shock and just missing my family and god
damn San Francisco January rainy winter
[ __ ]
but I also was then mandated that I had
to stay home for a full two weeks where
I'm just on drugs the whole time and I
think that I probably would have fallen
into depression and just hated
everything and had a really difficult
time recovering if it weren't for the
fact that I was playing the witness
during that period of time and it did
take me that two full weeks to finish
because I was on so many drugs I was
just sleeping most of the time so
basically what I was doing with sleeping
and then in my waking hours playing this
game with one of my roommates that is
very difficult in terms of puzzle
solving and pad with that gives you an
incredible sense of accomplishment
especially because there are no
tutorials in the witness' I don't know
if you guys have played it but basically
the tutorial is all entirely a visual
puzzle that you're watching so you
figure things out by solving the
simplest version of that thing without
it even telling you how that functions
now I love the language and the witness
is just fantastic but then it evolves
really rapidly and as a point where you
know I have a piece of paper and a
protractor and a mirror and I'm solving
puzzles all my roommate is and we're
just pulling out these drawings and then
pulling mirrors up because that one's
mirrored on screen so like how would
this look if it were backwards and like
figuring all this [ __ ] out that just
gave me this incredible sense of
accomplishment something to look forward
to every day and you know some of them
are auditory puzzles some of them a
visual puzzle some of them a timing
puzzles
and they're all segmented on different
parts of this island so I felt like I
was both progressing having a sense of
accomplishment and walking in something
that is just incredibly beautiful and it
was just the most uplifting escape that
I just can't imagine what I would have
done if I didn't have the witness to
play in that period of time and
constantly feel that sense of reward and
that that thing to look forward to where
you know your brain can't really even
comprehend anything else because I was
just on coding the whole time and I'm
like and forever thankful for the
witness for that period of time because
I feel like I you did you have you ever
told this story to Jon blow no I've
never met Jon blow my experience with
Jon blow is largely being like damn you
Jon bow because the witness is so
[ __ ] hot it's [ __ ] you like it's
it's I mean I feel like it would be any
developer's dream to basically hear how
helpful there especially a game like
this that's so kind of unconventionally
therapeutic like no I don't think people
would typically pinpoint this as a game
that helped them through a hard time
because it because precisely because of
how hard it is you know to what I was
going through but I do recommend it to
people who are sick face if you're
bedridden and that is such a very very
common thing with anyone who's had a
chronic illness or a any kind of
disability that prevents you from
leaving the house is you think about
being physically ill but you don't think
about what that does to you mentally
because like when the periods of time I
my chronic fatigue has been washed it
eats at you mentally because you feel
like you're wasting your life and you
get very frustrated at your own body
because you can't just get better and
you'll wake up every day and be like I
[ __ ] hate myself why don't I just get
better this is so frustrating for me so
I think games like the witness for
people who are mentally okay but
physically not okay are so helpful again
for that sense of accomplishment but
also the community of the witness was
really fantastic I did play it
significantly later than when it came
out but just talking to other people
about playing the witness and you know
their experiences with that game was
incredible especially because there are
so many like hidden puzzles and then
this is final challenge that I've still
never done that's a timed randomized
area you have to get through by the time
that the whole of the Mountain King
plays in full
which you know is a something that
dramatically escalates in like intensity
it's very cool but no I've never spent
gonna jump blow about it but generally
like I do recommend the witness to do
anyone who is physically debilitated all
the time and I feel like did you um did
you get sick and then start it or had
you started it and just kept rolling now
that you were bedridden I got sick and
my roommate started playing and while I
was home so she's a dentist and I was
working I think three days a week maybe
so she started it and I happened to be
there I don't know that I would have had
the motivation to do it myself cuz like
an illness like no money you really just
want to do sit in bed but like I'm sure
I still kind of was after sitting on the
couch next to her but you know having an
incredible time but no I had not started
it myself I don't know that I would have
had the motivation to in that period of
time I think I would have just sat in
bed watch TV and been miserable but
instead I look back at what could have
been a really dark period of time it's
something that I think probably would
have had a long-term effects on me
mentally if I had not recovered from
that I think I probably would have just
stayed miserable and and associated that
with having left home and maybe I feel
like it would've been a lot hotter but
instead I actually think about that
period of time when I had pneumonia as
being like wow that coughs sucked but
also I loved that game and I loved that
experience and I'm very very glad that I
had that in my life at that period of
time so basically I wanted to use an
episode of this podcast to talk about a
if you guys have had any experiences
like that I'll be if you've had anyone
who has played something that you've
made tell you a similar story I have one
other question if you guys don't mind
I'm sorry this is becoming me
interviewing a lot of but I was me last
week it's just it's so it's so evocative
and and but another question that I
thought was especially given what we
were just talking about a minute ago
with the hardwiring of smells and men
and tastes and all that kind of stuff
what was that before we were I don't
remember the show I'm not sure it's time
to remind people that we need to just
wear love mics and just just tune in and
out periodically Truman Show style but I
was curious if if you've gone
back to the witness if it if it's like
if it the memory of it is positive but
if you were to play it today
does it recon jure all the like smells
and horrible associations of how you
physically felt to where you can't enjoy
it or it because that happens to me I'll
have a positive experience of something
helping me in a given window of time but
it the memory of everything about that
experience comes with it now today like
certain movies you know all they'll take
me back where all the good and the bad
resurfaced so I just kind of leave them
be as a result even though it's a
positive memory I have played the
witness with other people because
there's a game that I champion now like
I love the witness a whole lot and no I
think that basically what it did for me
was erase the negative memory so like
what I picture when I picture myself
playing the witnesses me sitting on a
couch bundled up that F I mentioned
roommate was Vietnamese and she kept
making me this like very specific tea
that her mom always used to make her
when she was sick it's like full of all
these hubs that I felt tasted absolutely
terrible but she was like it'll work I
swear and I feel like it may have was
like colic and it was like so I
remembered that but I mostly remember
the feeling the feeling of
accomplishment and and the colors and
the sounds of that game rather than
smelling that tea is the only way to the
point is that it it erased the negative
memory entirely and then replaced it
with a positive one where if I didn't
have this game or maybe some other
outlet maybe some other kind of video
game where I feel like like Animal
Crossing for me right now is probably
helping me a lot with the self isolation
period of time I would probably just
remember having pneumonia in that
particular time is one of the most
miserable experiences of my life but now
I don't I feel like I remember it as the
time a good friend and I finished the
witness and how awesome that was and and
know I celebrate it for sure I like tell
people to play the game I'd be happy to
watch them play the game especially
because again it's so [ __ ] hard that
I forgotten all the puzzles who knows
how to solve them you could have yaki
you could show me one and I'd be like I
don't know these goddamn snake [ __ ]
I have no idea god damn you John Blaha
so I that's brain as a computer yeah
there's that and you've seen the behind
the scenes
the secret ending for the witness no I
didn't know about the one with the
pistols yeah it says I've never seen
that was a guess if you if you turn
around and you pull his balls I can
actually see some I think on the top you
know if it comes out red you really
gotta go to a doctor this this is
because it's a weird the way it's weird
that we've not talked about Star Wars
there's no if this is what Coke is sold
as in galaxy's edge I just can't wait
until we get the inevitable Daisy Ridley
versus Thanos you know that's when
that's when Disney will just be full
Disney you know
yeah the collision of IPS strong wakes
in for light yes Daisy Ridley's in there
no we can make that happen
I'm sure there's really no walls
characters and I think trailer revealing
for tonight well they they had the
Emperor's the transmission at the
Emperor sends in the opening crawl was
in fortnight and not in the movies man
which is I I mean I'll as a marketing
gimmick I think that's freaking cool it
was it was a little cheesy and I have
you know we've certainly talked plenty
about the Star Wars movies but I but
yeah I remember thinking like I love the
the kind of unconventional sort of like
because Star Wars is so sacred to so
many folks the the kind of cooling down
of that a little bit to be like how
about we just put a major plot point
well I may not be a semi purported to be
major but actually inconsequential plot
point in a video game that's utterly
unrelated to Star Wars like the thinking
that leads you there I find cool even if
I think there's very little else about
it I find cool for night is is
effectively I mean I feel like it's a
game that doesn't get a lot of respect
and I personally do not enjoy playing it
but I think it is just the way it
approaches events like that marketing in
general and the evolution of the game is
incredible
I think event gaming is the future yeah
I think it's something that everyone
should stand up and take notice and go
this is the way that we could do this
from now on is is on this date this
thing will happen and everybody just
comes and rose and they experience this
thing and then it's it's that's to me
that's right now except that it's not
typically a multiplayer game is everyone
is playing pot in the Easter event which
is you know I've had MMO segments that I
played on and off forever and it will
always go for winter events because I
just love a white Christmas even though
I've never had one that's like I get to
experience one even though I've never
seen one before yeah my my favorite
go-to for that the notion of a gaming
event because it's so committed to that
is do you remember I think Troy you and
I've talked about this at length but in
fact I think this was a project of
Romney's was to remember a glitch hiker
oh my god do you guys know about that I
talk about this all the time tell them
it's brilliant it's it was it was I
might be getting some of the details a
little bit wrong because it's it's been
a number of years I saw it isn't it
about at GDC and the experimental
gameplay workshop where it's a game that
the game itself in a static way not just
not just like in an absolute way not
localized to your system but in the
world the game has a finite number of
lives so every time you die the game
takes a hit
not your chance of replaying the result
of which is that basically if enough
players [ __ ] it up it's sort of self
destructs and the code is erased in the
game just disappears forever and so it
very quickly developed you know because
the think the thing only lasted like six
hours or something before because all it
takes is one troll to completely ruin
the game and so as a result all these
people started working overtime where
they're like pulling like is this you
know they sat down to play for an hour
and they play for five hours trying to
keep it alive if you played well you
would maintain it I think yeah I think
if i if i were lives to the game by
going out and doing certain things you
could find gold or whatever it was that
keep the game alive but it was lower
than six hours man it was it was
something like and
I've been a couple of days I should look
it up and know definitively but I just
remember thinking the notion that the
game is finite and then literally they
said in the presentation you know it's
gone now it's dead and and and we wrote
it to take the code with it like we
would have to make it from scratch if we
wanted to redo and I remember thinking
as a game oh the curiosity the opposite
of that where everyone was like trying
to get to the end of this game and I
played it pretty often but you all you
did was tap cubes you're trying to get
to the end of it and someone got a prize
and the price was not good did you ever
watch did you ever read like the
follow-up like articles didn't end up
working it it was it was like yeah
there's lots of controversy around it
yeah around is really the there's also
there's a few I think a few I feel bad
by mentioning them but there's a few
games like that that exists like where
there's only one copy of the game and
gets passed to you and then you're the
only person who gets to play it for that
there's a few of these that kind of
these kind of comic half of them are
like urban legends like yeah I go back
and forth because a few years ago
wu-tang clan did an album where they
made a single like gold vinyl or
whatever and the only way to hear it was
to sign an NDA surrender your phone and
go to like a controlled listening party
and they basically toured the vinyl
around and I remember when I first read
that I was like that's the most sort of
arrogant you know and they I think they
even said you know or you can buy it for
a million dollars or something like that
I think someone did he didn't that
affected fool man yeah Martin shkreli or
whatever I think he was actually the one
who bought it and yeah you're right
that's so funny but yeah I remember it's
part of me my initial reaction to that
story was like that's so stupid
partly because for me my whole MO is
about sharing it is about finding ways
to connect with people as widely and
broadly as possible so but at the same
time
the notion of kind of the ephemeral and
you know it's like when you go to a
great meal you don't think how do I
preserve this forever you you know I
must enjoy this moment because it in an
hour or two or three it's gone
and so I do have that kind of
romanticized view of the things that
must be cherished in the moment and
sorry I kind of go back and forth now on
the whole Wu Tang album thing cuz
there's part of me that wants to do an
album like that as well that's like it
it it it can only you know it will come
and go briefly a game but you have to
give me a million dollars
even yeah grant game plays he has a
YouTube channel with markiplier where
they're uploading a video every single
day and then as soon as I think it's
sometime in November for a full year as
soon as that year is done they're just
getting getting under all of it really
just as an experiment they kind of just
wanted to see what would happen of
course other people could download the
videos they do I think have have
preventive measures but in part well
like we kinda just want to see what
people do with this and what it does to
the community and the last I spoke to
them about it they were saying people
are coming earlier and really heavily
trying to share this thing with one
another in the comments like much more
than you would see on an average video
that they're really trying to sort of
shape an experience for everyone who is
partaking and watching these videos
every day which is I guess part of being
limited it's been a really positive sort
of social experiment for them
yes we don't like when things go extinct
we don't like to what what is that is it
the finality if if Emerson says that the
all of history exists for the sake of a
single person then is it is if that can
go extinct that I mixed thing is it
we're like what what do you think that
is socially pretentious but my
assumption would be because it's tied to
like the greatest fear anyone has right
which is death which we don't like leads
to end yeah yeah you hope you hope for
logic like most human hopes are tied to
longevity right there having a you know
having loved the lost forever having an
eternity in heaven you know that kind of
yeah it's all about living longer right
like it's all tied to that yeah my guess
is a lot more cynical which is that
people like feeling
like that part of an exclusive club yeah
you see a lot more negative way to look
at that but I feel like that's just such
a big part of the gaming community
unfortunate like a lot of negative takes
I worry it might be the right one yeah
as people superiority for experiencing
something that other people won't be
able to it's probably both and probably
most people have both in them in kind of
evolving ratios of which one is sort of
the dominant but I definitely feel what
you're talking about Troy of the the
there's something very powerful about
knowing something is fragile and that
it's sort of I remember I had an I once
went to the San Diego Zoo I'm not really
I don't really like going to zoos
they're always a very depressing but for
whatever reason a few years ago I went
to the not it wasn't the San Diego Zoo
it was there they're kind of sister
organization that's kind of more sort of
more like Jurassic Park you know it's
like it's not really like a life so far
a kind of thing yeah that it's called
like the Cal is that what it is wild
safari it's something it's has a name
like that it's like the safari park or
whatever where it's just huge open sort
of tracts of land it's less about like
here's the exhibit of this animal in
that animal and and they're one of their
big appeals is that you can zipline over
this giant thing with all these roaming
animals below you and where you you
can't like get in a you know you don't
you don't walk through there you know
the the carefully manicured path through
their stuff I'm sorry could we just
Allegra miss so you can zipline over a
lion I think it's it's more like over
giraffes or something but I don't lose
that title right quite significantly off
the ground but it but the thing was so
up until a couple of years ago when she
finally died they had literally the the
last or the second to last ever white
rhino there and they said that and I
remember so they walked past this sort
of pond where I was just sitting there
kind of sleeping in the Sun and hanging
out and they said this is an is a
species that is functionally extinct
even though there are two of them one is
here and the other one is is somewhere
and once he had the other one
[ __ ] define I can't remember yeah she
just was only one like seesaw rubber
rider that's it like stream sports
goodbye there's a chance to taste
extinct species yeah no I was it was
actually the thing was it was a
profoundly emotional experience to like
and you know it's one of those that I
consider myself I don't I don't I don't
like to think of myself as a pathetic at
all to conservationism or
environmentalism as causes there's just
other causes I tend to prioritize in my
use of time and money and resources and
things like that and which made it all
the more surprising to me that that just
sitting and staring at this animal and
just imagining kind of
anthropomorphizing the perspective and
thinking I wonder what it would be like
to sit there knowing you're the last
ever of your kinds of you're very sweet
about that it just was so poignant to me
to think like I am actually looking at
the legitimate end of a legacy like
there is a multi-billion year
evolutionary legacy that culminates on
one branch in this actual animal
nevermind this species this actual
example of that species represents the
end of a really long women there was
something really really effecting about
that that was like the Great Barrier
Reef all the time as a kid because my
mom worked in hotels basically I I was
born in Cannes which is the main
take-off point for the Great Barrier
Reef is I went all the time probably
once a month we'd go diving so in the
Great Barrier Reef most beautiful thing
I've ever seen
other than all the lights just just
absolutely incredible so glad to have
seen it and then I moved from Cannes I
think when I was maybe 12 or so and I've
thought about that before that now it
looks completely different even in that
amount of time it's been however many
years and it's completely dead and I
didn't know what I was looking at I
wonder I love that period of time and I
always thought it was incredible
and beautiful and I have all these very
vivid memories of swimming looking at
the Great Barrier Reef and there are
certain kinds of fish that would try to
attack your flippers for some reason and
certain fish that would just stare at
you and like the way that they would
school to get it's just just this
beautiful thing but I had no idea that
it was dying when I was doing that but I
would I have felt more positively about
it if I knew what was happening to it at
the time or am I better off for having
this untarnished pure childhood memory
of this thing without knowing because I
don't think I in any way contributed to
the downfall of the Great Barrier Reef
so it's not like I made it any worse but
I don't think that I quite knew that
what I was looking at or had the
comprehension to know that what I was
looking at was not permanent even though
it wasn't I don't know I genuinely have
no idea I feel like I'm been equate
knowing if someone had specifically told
you to straight up you know this is
fragile this can't this won't
necessarily it's I mean even at that age
would you have even kind of yet been
able then I had been told but the
Australian rhetoric at the time was we
will fix it so my head was always there
gonna fix it it's gonna society has
learned since then our presumption about
figure it out we'll get it back to life
but when corals dead you can't bring
coral back to life they figured they'd
be able to breed coral and maybe plant
more coral it just it just doesn't walk
well surely it works you just need a
couple of hundred thousand years to run
that experiment I am I feel that because
I've experienced both I've experienced
you know things where you go and you're
like you have to see this because this
is that this won't be here and this is
this is a fleeting thing and so you're
like okay and so you're just constantly
hyper viewing everything through this
lens of this could be gone and that's
one experience and then others were you
had no idea that then you would never
sits the same thing of the people that
we've nose like most people say I didn't
that was the last time I was gonna see
them and the purity and the naivete that
you got to use we just had a cup of
coffee or I you have this kind of I
can't help but think for me
that the moments that I've had when
someone has told me this is the
experience that you must have I'm
immediately taking out of being in the
moment because I'm already in that
moment where that thing will no longer
exist or not be there or whatever and so
I don't really like I didn't I I've been
to Venice I'm like it's Venice it's
beautiful but I was told I needed to go
there because it's not gonna be there
anymore and and so that you're ticking a
box right that's that I'm ticking a box
exactly and I'm framing it by the reason
why I'm here is to see that's not
because I felt this draw to go to st.
Mark's Square now all of the moments
that I had there are indelible for a
completely different reason other than
the scarcity or though the short live
Innis of that of that city even though
it's been there for centuries but the
fact that it was never supposed to be
there it was a it was a refugee camp for
Christians fleeing persecution they all
showed up in the swamp and started
building and it was never supposed to be
there was like people calling a life
raft a cruise ship it's like no that's
not what this was intended to be but
then you go to another like a
significant thing where like Notre Dame
and the last time I was there I always
make sure that I appreciate seeing it
because it's one of my favorite pieces
of architecture in the planet but I had
no idea the next time that I would see
it would never look the same way because
of the fire yeah in sight
to not read on and that means at any
time that I'm trying to figure out how
to get home I just figure out where not
Radames to to then get to my hotel and
I've done that every time which is not I
make three times for work but every time
that I've done that I that is my homing
beacon I have my coffee there every
morning before I go out and I feel like
you're facing if you're facing the the
Nostradamus that that little cafe that's
just there to the left for the streets
gonna converge you're talking about and
I'll usually like take a coffee with me
and then sit in that park that is in
front of the Nostradamus so I would
actually be facing the building would be
behind me but I love it there and I
thought about that when it when it
burned which
you know I still had this relationship
with that where I'm like I wish that the
billionaires had put money into
something else other than an old church
and it drives me nuts but I feel like if
I had known I would have looked at it
with or associated it with sadness
because you're then forcing something on
it but I had this these memories of this
this building that I loved Gothic
architecture anyway I think that
building is just so cool that I just
don't think about it that way at all and
and the lack of permanence as far as
that concern doesn't doesn't upset me as
much in my memories it's completely
untainted because I didn't know in that
case I prefer to not know I think but in
terms of like family every time I leave
my family in Australia I'm my brain is
programmed to think you don't know when
you're gonna be home next treat this
like this loss time you gonna sing any
of them and my [ __ ] grandma who's 96
every time goes I probably won't see you
again laughs and like what the [ __ ]
that's such a beautiful shining example
of stoicism and lovely it's like yeah to
live is preferred but I'm okay with
death I've done this kid I've been
around it's really upset right now
because she lost her job at a volunteer
clothing center whether it's basically
it's called st. Vinnie's in Australia
Sigma Red Cross if you have that yes
she's very upset that she's lost her job
we were like in 96 should take the time
you're gonna be just fine
she's clearly she's clearly just using
that as an excuse and that she's
obviously very lazy I think it's about
she's signaling and she was I feel like
again a lot of you let us down this
great path and kicked us off with such
an incredible story yeah I want to be
the only one I can go oh my yeah I'll go
so the first part but kind of have you
worked on stuff I suspect probably all
of us have had that the honor of working
on something that's kind of touched
someone in that way and it's yeah it is
awesome I'm always kind of reticent to
like point to a story because always
seem so self-serving to be like here's a
story of how I changed someone's life
but yeah I think with Thomas was alone
in particular like that game
definitely connects with people who are
I think it's also and this was never the
intention but I think it kind of
specifically because of the title Thomas
was alone I think it is a game that
jumps out people who are in a dark place
yeah and I think what's surprising is
and people who've not played it assume
that it's kind of a mopey emo game and
it really isn't it's kind of a silly
comedy game then why did you get micros
do the soundtrack I should have got my
Chemical Romance instead I got David
Houston insisted on pop fun but it's
kind of so I think it kind of it's
almost like a kind of Trojan horse of
positivity that kind of comes into
people's lives and they think it's gonna
be one thing and then it's it's it's
very different so I think I think that's
helped people and yes those messages
it's advice they're nice it's really if
anyone watching this if something's
taught you like that the person who made
it definitely wants to love to hear and
you would brighten their day by telling
them that I'm on the give me more than
that read it could be more than just
brighten their day like sometimes
creators are constantly contending with
like imposter syndrome and crippling
self-doubt and sometimes Curtis that
positive feedback can be like the reason
to keep creative I've had it literally
I've had a day where something the way
like I've had like a setback on a piece
of work or something's falling through
or whatever and then yes like you say
you don't have the the message the
Twitter DM or whatever of like hey your
thing helped me I think
yeah it's amazing it can give you that
whole thing of like I can do the next
thing and definitely like it's inspired
some of the stuff we're currently
working on like you know that positivity
and wanting to do something good in that
way and then in terms of what I like I'm
actually I can't go the complete
opposite way to you Ilana with the stuff
I like when I'm in a bad place is always
like very guided very linear very don't
let me make a decisions for me because
my job is so much about making decisions
for me relaxation is often night I
mentioned Lego the other day we were
chatting like Lego is amazing cuz it's
someone else telling me what to do I get
to role play being creative and being an
engineer the first thing I did when I
when I thought I was probably gonna have
to stay home a bit more was order a
bunch of Lego because that stuff just
keeps me ticking over and kinda gives me
lets me just sit back and be sit behind
the level there
designer who's made that okay go oh
that's really clever how you sell about
that thing a little while ago all you
just taught me how to do that joint so
that when I get to three more later I
feel clever because you set that up and
kind of even the way instructions are
organized with Lego does that in terms
of games though like I mean I'm playing
a lot of I'm playing all the call of
juvie single-player campaigns again
because they've just released two is the
two I'm back on now I'm playing the
first one I'm gonna get to the second
one one of the best games ever brilliant
and lots of fun and absolutely no play a
choice absolutely no creativity just run
forward and stay behind that guy and
shoot stuff and genuinely like that just
is so nice and relaxing for me right now
the kind of I'm reverting to those kind
of games I feel like I'm kind of yeah
very linear very simple stuff I find
comfort in just being you know comfort
food I guess it's comfort food ever play
that Back to the Future game so the
telltale did like I think I played I
think I feel like I played like the
first two or three episodes yeah man I
think there were only three episodes oh
maybe I don't I definitely think I
finish I got to like it was the I got to
the brown where Doc Brown was like
dictator so I'm like halfway or
something I think yeah that's that's
yeah that it is the that is the fourth
movie it to me that the telltale agates
very much like that to what is it that
good I didn't realize oh my god it's so
good it's in my Steam library because
the number of years ago telltale did a
by everything we've released for 50
bucks or whatever so I have I have
literally everything they made in my
Steam library and I haven't played 3/4
of them you shouldn't play it be Back to
the Future Borderlands wolf among us
Walking Dead definitely don't play
Batman he's such a terrible voice actor
I feel like the only one that I've
played that I didn't like was Game of
Thrones Game of Thrones I'm sorry was
awful and that was it was that did you
play the Minecraft no Ickes minecraft
and Game of Thrones were just cash
grabby
Monkey Island wasn't
yeah I was gonna say monkey island was
the was didn't understand what monkey on
monkey island but that was their whole
thing where it's like what if we flip it
on its here it was like yeah you can
give me that but but but honestly the
best one that they got was Back to the
Future and it is so much fun to explore
in that world of if when I played it it
felt like someone allowed me to just
wander through that lot that back lot
and the set of that and interact with
characters that were just in the
background
it already is of course the the tour for
that is like 20 miles away from where
yourself right now not even that mate
it's really really close oh yeah that
could be a universal like that well
that's yeah there's a there's still the
downed airplane that that came in what
is that what's I was that from that was
more the world's that's what it was
it's it's crazy - I remember the psycho
house now it's a good place as well
because they have the old the old it was
an old I feel like it was an old Mexican
town they built for westerns years ago
that they painted like pastel colors
yeah a good place and that's on the tour
as well and good places on good places
on the lot and then if you go to the
ranch you get to see the friends
fountain and all sorts of cool stuff too
but I don't know Austin oh no if you
remember this or not but walking out
because at the time I lived in North
Hollywood I walked out of my of my
apartment and I looked in the sky I was
like that's not supposed to be there and
there's just this plume of smoke and it
was the archives that caught my eye out
I was like with that holy [ __ ] what's on
fire I lost some real [ __ ] that day they
lost some originals of 35 prints and and
old master tapes and stuff and it's
crazy again going back to the it's like
nowhere near compares to the Great
Barrier Reef but the same time I
remember feeling that tremendous sense
of loss of going movies that I'd never
seen shows that I had never watched were
gone and somewhere there may be some
version of
that but like that original print of
that that directors the culmination of
that cast and crew's work is gone and
it's the same thing as like III I've
been redoing my studio since since the
whole quarantine and and III have a real
hard time with throwing away stuff I'm
not a hoarder I'm not a pack rat but I
just especially comes to gear I'm like I
know that's an old fire wire to thing
I'll never eat it again but but what if
I do what if I do need it and there's
been so many things that I found was
like aha this is why I kept this cable
but I far too many USB leads I like I
don't need them in my life but it's it's
the whole thing of like the fear of loss
I've been on the other side of that when
I went to I've been fortunate after
visit Disney a couple of times and doing
the tour of their of the animation
studios and there is a building that to
go into it's the archive where they keep
the original original like prints of
like Sleeping Beauty on one holy [ __ ]
and in order to go into that building
you have to sign a waiver that you give
this me permission to kill you if they
have to because the way of the way if a
fire spreads in that archive the only
way the the only way they can plow a
fire is to cut the oxygen out of the
room so by definition this the way to
protect that room because they can't
flooded with water that wouldn't work
and so it's all y'all it's ridiculously
vulnerable right so so they they have
baby bears like a waiver which is
basically like if if if we let you in
this room and I I wasn't in no way
important enough to go and be in that
room but if you if you wanna be in this
room you have to basically sign a waiver
saying they can cut the oxygen from that
room and they're not liable for the lack
of oxygen being a problem for you how
much is your life worth I really never
know exactly that was my thought process
I was like you know what that sounds
fair I give it a choice between me or
the entire Disney library and I the the
world
the world needs then more than me right
like that's my it's my goal also
to have a very noteworthy death cause
it's one hell of a way to die yeah I
like that needs to be in the headline
like it shouldn't be just like as much
as I appreciate the sentiment and I
joined man dies force like beauty
surrounded by loved ones and whatnot
it's like what they all got pulled into
the archive lack of oxygen also like to
me I want there to be a I want there to
be a story right in in amidst that
that's the main one in life is go to
space speaking of John Hurt man if I
were to ever get terminally ill like
that what he did in contact hell yeah
man the diamonds oh you haven't seen
contact I'm not gonna have a massive I'm
surprised that we've only just gotten to
this lapse in in films and TV because my
whole life I've just played video games
and have had okay like I watch my first
Tarantino movie last year i watch The
Godfather I've only just like all of
these major films just recently did you
watch one or two were both did you just
watch the first life but no John Hurt in
contact you know he's this brilliant
billionaire eccentric that ends up
funding the the Wersching of we have for
sure why does one when you can build to
double the cost but he he's sick and
he's dying throughout the end of the
course of the movie and not to spoil it
but the book came out forty years ago so
now he ends up going to space and he's
just got this great moment he's just so
stoic about it he says apparently the
lack of gravity is the only thing that's
keeping the cancer from eating my body
alive and as it's just beautiful that
that the way that he's this side
character whose life actually reflects
everything that's happening on earth
they Carl Sagan is is just one of life's
level yeah next level man I met his wife
and
yes absolutely one of my heroes like
100% in a way that I've tried to model
some of the stuff that I do off to him
in a way that he was a person who had a
wealth of knowledge and his only Emma
was to share it with every other person
as excessively as possible in a way that
everything that he knew he wanted
everyone else to be able to know should
they want to without being preachy in a
way that he's not talking down anyone
he's not passionate geniuses it was
filled with Wonder and that's the thing
that I loved about him everything that
he did was not there was no derision
there was no condemnation for anything
everything had Wonder attached to it and
as Austin has has not only exemplified
but also helped me frame and drawn me to
it's to love the question not to seek
the answer to be much more to chase
after the questions and and and love why
and love them not knowing more than it
is proving the answer that I have or
needing to have the answer that I don't
some [ __ ] that's so raven to the point
of like losing permanence i kept wanting
to say that though at this very absurd
thing where occasionally i just think
about the fact that the library of
alexandria bone down and get sad wasn't
in my lifetime i have no idea what was
in that i have no knowledge of what that
even looked like really that's why it is
a tragedy [ __ ] proms me out and like
the knowledge that could have been in
there that people put in that because
for anyone who doesn't know basically
anyone who passed into the city any book
they had they would keep they would
replicate the book and give it back to
you but you don't they had the replica
they would have the original was a rule
for actually going there like the walk
yeah yes i had this period growing up
where I became obsessed the Library of
Alexandria also and I and so I whether
that may very well be true but for sure
that was the whole idea it's like a
trade hub that had the whole world's
knowledge and essentially at that time
gives me goosebumps thinking about it
how awesome that is as a thing which I
mean yeah sure that kind of exists only
in
but I mean that's an incredible resource
we don't give the instant enough credit
for how much you can one I used to what
I was drunk I just go in these rabbit
holes right like long about a black hole
a lot about an African killaby a lot
about the inflation crisis in Zimbabwe
have all of these like these are actual
things that I looked up that like
genuinely I'd just be drunk and be like
what do I want to learn about today you
can just you the fact that you can do
that on the Internet is amazing it's
that's no is it no that's the difference
between me yeah do you about that
hyperinflation man they could they would
have to take giant bags to the bank
because the currency was so worthless
that to even take the currency out it's
like a suitcase for $2 nuts everyone
should read more history it's just yeah
really fun thing to like history's
better than any fictions I've been
written absolutely we have time I highly
recommend checking out yeah history from
the free from 0 ad mm I however do not
have time because I'm gonna have to jump
off
well then Troy what's your answer - yeah
the one that actually had picked out
plastic scissors with it that yeah is
this there's so many easy punch sells
Bob yes I'll tells Batman the first game
that employed me I have I have a
treasure trove of stories of like Mike
said games that we've been a part of
that haven't meant something to other
people the one that I kept coming back
to you and I thought about your question
a lot Alana and I wanted to give it the
respect that it deserves but for some
reason the answer that keeps coming back
to me is a crystallis or Chris Tallis
however you prefer to say it which was a
1990 I think in 1990 NES game I had I
went through a period of time where
every night all I did was I went online
with my friends and we played and that
whole thing fell apart and so I had
packed up every console that I had and I
took it out of my room and I wanted
nothing to do with it because just like
you talked about the the possible
of the surrounding contextual experience
that you have for the pneumonia or
whatever could potentially taint gaming
and playing for you that that did it for
me I was like I don't want to do this
anymore and so I got rid of everything
and then we started doing the show and I
just got really hip to playing I got
that my first retropie that it allowed
me to go back and play these old NES
games and I remember that there was a
game that I started for my I guess would
have been my tenth or eleventh birthday
and I was allowed to across the highway
from where we lived two lane highway it
doesn't matter was a video store and
they did not only do they movies but
they also you could rent an NES and one
game for 24 hours for like 10 bucks and
that was about all the money that my
parents had to spend for me from my
birthday and so that's what I did I had
24 hours to beat this game and you could
order the books you know but at that
time guys yeah the guy it's but there
was no you know this is before yeah this
is nes so there was there was no there's
no saves you know if you turn the
Machine off you're done and I that you
also know what nobody knew it was like
oh Legend of Zelda is when you're gonna
play there was no review there was no
Metacritic you just went you're like I
don't know the key art on this box looks
cool I'm gonna buy that one and it's
just the one that wasn't rented right
that was always my story you ended up
choosing things because no one else had
so crystallis was see he was up here as
like I don't know grab this one and play
it looks pretty cool and I got so far in
the game and then for the last 30 years
that game has sat unfinished for me and
I looked through the library of all the
games that that had and that was on
there and it's like well if I could beat
it and I did and I spent the next like I
think a week playing through that and
it's it's a obviously a single-player
game and that reminded me that what
gaming had become for me it didn't have
to be that it could just be my
experiences in that and if I could feel
good about that then potentially I could
feel good about other things so I
remember the the I have a screenshot of
it the night that I finally finished
that game in the final frame of that
game I watched it with my phone and I
took a picture and I cried because I was
like the the 11 year old kid in me was
standing next to me in that moment and I
just want to look at him and go it's
gonna be okay because there's some of
the best moments and worst moments I've
had been with games and that game is
what kind of said why don't you pick up
the next game and watch pick up the next
game so oddly enough it's it's a game
from 1990 that actually carried me
through a hard time and and it's been
one of the most my most impactful games
was there a wistfulness to finishing it
like finally closing that door yeah dude
like like I walked out of my room and I
think Pam was in the living room or
something I just kind of walked out
slowly and I said I did it and she knew
exactly what it was because that's all I
would walk out of my room at times would
be like okay so I have the sword of the
wind but I don't have a fire bracelet
and then I just need you to understand
what this means right now because the
world that I'm in you know it was it was
one of those beautiful moments like
probably like you have with witness I've
intentionally never finished banjo-tooie
which is one of my favorite games ever
because that game makes me think of my
childhood so much and I play that game
every year on my birthday I will play
banjo tooie and I have this weird
feeling that I know is irrational where
I feel like if I finished that game that
I would be closing my childhood that's
the way I've always felt about it I
don't know why I don't know where that
came from well when I decided that but
at some point I was like I will never
finish that game because every year on
my birthday I go back and I play that
game and I remember being a kid and
playing my n64 and very similarly like I
loved so many experiences where I would
rent an n64 game and be in someone
else's world like with majora's mask or
Jeff was gem and I was one for me I'd
read them before I could buy them my
parents didn't have any money when I was
a kid so a lot of it was rentals and
then buying something secondhand wait
wait wait wait oh so you get someone
else's save file and you see the worlds
they experience and I could never bring
myself to delete anyone
this wealth it's like I loved that I was
getting to explore what they had done
not knowing who they were because that
should be a game Mike imagine if there
was like a like like an open-world PSP a
PlayStation prestige open-world game
like you know horizon or I was trying to
I was gonna list every open-world game
horizon and then you ran out of games
[Laughter]
last week I was like I have to go play
the crew you guys that's what I'm doing
and then I play the crew and I'm like is
that Troy it's always Troy but anyway my
podcast my point is like yeah I think I
thinkwell since that's true like I would
be really cool in the game if you could
play one of those and you could like
grab your friend save and just kind of
yet walk around the town that that
character is existed in and hear stories
about the things they've done that's
kind of a badass idea okay fine 150 but
you know obviously we'll have to scope
the game it's it's related to how I can
remember I have this weird feeling I
brought this up maybe last week or the
week before it's forgive me if this
doesn't but I remember I remember Bob
Evans watched this 90-minute cut of The
Godfather
no I started yeah it was um I I remember
when I was a student I went to the
student bookstore and they had her the
student library I mean at USC and they
had a shelf that was like these are all
you know retired books basically just
take it if you want it free of charge
and there was a yeah that's basically
the story of Mike's bathroom is a
bookshelf
yeah I can't wait for you to pull up the
copy of the book I'm about to mention
would you be amazing I have no idea the
the heart attack that would cause this
be just unreal but the they had an old
music theory textbook from like the 50's
that was this proposition
of like a different way of thinking
about me
and and that's where you're supposed to
mykes but say like which edition would
you say I realize I have about music is
one the history of musical theater on
guessing it wasn't that way it wasn't
that now this was this was like this was
like a pedagogical text about music
theory except it was writing it it was
it didn't it didn't it didn't take
because we have like this system of
music theory that's been refined and
developed over hundreds hundreds of
years and then this composer and the in
the 20th century around that maybe the
40s or 50s Paul Hindemith said I have a
different idea and no one really adopted
his idea so this book or this series of
books kind of came and when he's very
well respected as a one of the great
kind of classical composers of the 20th
century but but I never even knew about
this and it was sitting there for free
and it was like an old old old copy beat
to hell and so I remember I picked it up
and I just was curious started reading
it you know as a music nerd and what I
loved about it and it changed my book
buying habit forever was that some
student or probably multiple generations
of students had had to use this book as
their textbook so it was full of
highlighting and underlining and the
best part was because this was this
represented a rejected methodology there
was a lot of like sarcastic comments
written in the margins from people that
he would say things like you know there
would be a comment saying you know this
this this now arms you with a proper
tool for analyzing harmony or something
larger that be like I bet it does sure
you know you you're damn right Paulie or
whatever like you could say these are
terrible people for all I know the worst
our frustrated musicians in writing in
the margins and I felt like I was having
a conversation with a stranger who I
will never know anything about and it
was so exciting and so and it added this
third dimension to the reading
experience of like it's no longer just
me and the author there's this other
audience member that I from then on I
only was buying books on Amazon that
were like the one penny version because
they're so damaged that's what
that I by Kendall I love a secondhand
book and I will sell them again as soon
as I'm finished with their yeah it's
amazing to pass that on III struggle I
can't do that cuz I want to hold on to
them but Abe books a B e alpha Bravo
echo books is really really good
resource for stuff like that I've bought
several from them and they are basically
an aggregator for I I believe in going
to local book shops there's a great book
shop in London like called mags books
that's been there for Shepherds Bush I
think is where they are they've been
affairs whatever and I've held a
first-generation Moby Dick I've held the
first generation arms in the Covenant
which was really cool what's the story
attached that is brilliant but I love
that matter-of-fact to piggyback on that
story that the copy of the arms that
cover that I held I asked him
specifically I was like what is your
favorite what book are you most proud of
that you have and he handed it to me and
was like what is this book I don't even
know what this book is and he shared it
with me that this was the book that
Churchill wrote as a treatise to inform
his friend at the time he was on the
opposite side of political spectrum that
the Nazis were going to invade and it
was up to Britain to stand in the way
otherwise this would just spill over to
the rest of the world and so he wrote
this treatise arms in the Covenant and
his friend who was the Prime Minister
took the book and he tossed it over his
shoulder threw it out the window and it
landed in the garden and his Vallot is
the one who went and retrieved it and it
picked it up he goes and that's the copy
that you're holding there it was a water
stain from it and it was it was in
personally inscribed by Churchill and I
was like holy crap man so it's it's
stories like that like you say you open
up and to to see someone's you know name
and you know 1947 or whatever it was
when they when they first read this book
I've done that to my copy of Marcus
meditations I just put my name in it at
least contributing because I like having
you are trying to think of my best
example of this and I think the one I
have is I own
dad's childhood chess set I mean biro
it's got all of where he drew dicks are
there as a toss man it's the coolest
thing like to have something that
belonged to my dad when he was a nice
clamorous is what you're describing
that's still really cool
I feel like Johnny as a game I mean does
that a little bit that's that's part of
the you can draw dicks in Johnny and
inspire whoever it no the fact that you
find out that you're playing with
someone who's assisting you all are you
playing with with someone else and not
just an AI is is a similar kind of
concept I think yeah that's oh it's
funny because I never I never thought
that would be a thing it was never it
was never our goal on that to trick
people into thinking this is a co-op
it's like a secret coop experience we we
I mean at least I don't recall that
being a conversation I remember they
intentionally wanted to take away every
possible means by which players might
troll each other just to try to purify
it to this very positive experience
where it's it's basically impossible to
not be and it's and it's very easy to
walk away if you're not feeling it and
so there was so much conversation on
that that never even dawned on me that
people would just assume it's some kind
of really clever AI oh yeah and and then
be shocked at the end to see the PSN
handles which by the way that is where
then the dick jokes if it we had that
once at a journey live show where we
finished the show and you know the game
ends with this song and you see the
credits and it's it's usually pretty
somber and we get these quiet rooms
sometimes you can really hear a pin drop
in there and you have a few hundred
people or some cases far more than that
in this and and and the tend to be very
wrapped with attention and then when
it's like companions met along the way
you know dick jockey 69 yeah it's one
particular one where that happened and
the audience just exploded and laughter
it ended up being the perfect because we
we are playing live networked and it's a
random stranger or multiple and so you
get it you get the real experience as a
concert in it but it was hilarious it
was one of those were is like okay well
you know I don't think it capped the
experience nicely
I'm a massively distracted cause
PlayStation just released the images of
the new controller it doesn't look like
the one I'd seen before now that's cool
I think the the pivot to the PS 5
controllers is a an excellent sign that
we should make our way I wanted to I
wanted to throw mine into this mix
because it's it's a it's an anomalous
one I guess kind of like the witness in
a way that it is a it is not a game it's
just it's just what dawned on me when
you first brought up the the the
question and I couldn't stop thinking
about it because I kept thinking really
that one because I haven't had a lot of
conversations about it since I played it
but it was Davey readin's game the
beginner's guide which was for me when I
met my worst like if I'm in a shitty
shitty place it that's usually very much
tied to the notion of creativity itself
and it's and especially you know all are
talking just a minute ago about
longevity and all that kind of crap I
think it's like if I feel suddenly
hampered in my ability to do the one
thing that I feel wired to do that's at
me at my most vulnerable and it's like
it's like my it's like going deaf would
be kind of my absolute worst nightmare
you could take away everything I could
be a brain-in-a-vat
Futurama style but if I can here I've
got I'm connected to the thing that is
sort of above all else for me and so
when I and I've had some really like few
years ago about five six years ago I had
starting this sort of 24 month period of
just absolute overwhelming darkness of
just everything that could go wrong did
go wrong from people in my life dying to
to having massive professional setbacks
you know marriage falling apart it was
like just it was it was just contour
country song it was I know it was it's
true I almost moved to Nashville and
started over no but actually ironically
that's the thing it was like the I could
feel that creative well drying I felt
and that was to me the sign that
everything truly was breaking at the
foundational level because it it was
always music as the escapism right music
is the thing that I when all else fails
I have this truly reliable safe harbor
and when I found myself in the midst of
all this [ __ ] and then turning to my
piano or turning to a piece of paper or
a sketch pad you know or turning to my
software and it just seemed like pulling
teeth music was coming out harder and
harder and harder I started Lee that's
when I realized like okay it's not just
that I'm in a kind of rough period but
something's actually broken something's
actually going on really wrong here and
this I don't know how to fit love to
address that what did they call it the
struggling artist is his [ __ ] we
should start romanticizing that because
people would tell you well you'll make
the best art when you're sad it's all
whole [ __ ]
well I think it depends it depends on
the flavor of your struggle right cuz
struggles can really be amazing Taylor's
inspiration but I think the idea that
you have to be sad have to be yes just
absurd that I completely I think it's do
either often it's do with your our
situation if you're under like our best
games have definitely the ones we've
created them under the most constrained
circumstances but we were happy while we
did it we were just enjoying being under
weird circumstances no question that
that but that's what you do you do kind
of hit it elana with that because I was
like the thing that made that game so in
powerfully healing for me was that it's
like a gamified walkthrough of just
examining creativity basically and
examining the interface of creativity
with sort of personal health and
happiness and it's a very introspective
game and the reason why it was so
powerful is it was like I kept stopping
the game and turning to my computer and
writing myself an email be like oh I
just got an idea for this I need to
remember later to go do this and it was
like it the game took me three times
long
than normal then like if I just went
straight through it because I was this
explosion of inspiration of ideas
unrelated to the game it just it would
it would it's like it got my
subconscious working again it put put
gas in the tank in a way that I I will
be so forever grateful to it and I
cherish it and I loved it but it was
like it was an essential sort of
treatment that I didn't know I needed
cuz I just play it you know it's like oh
I like Davies and I sky we're friendly
with each other and and Stanley parable
was a game that I I thought was cool and
and I thought you know presented
interesting ideas so I just kind of got
it on autopilot the way I often do when
someone noteworthy releases a game and
and I just dove in completely blind and
it was like it's not like it was this
cure-all and and it I don't mean to
mischaracterize it as because that would
imply my problems were actually quite
shallow but it it reminded me what it
felt like to kind of have that fire of
inspiration and help reorient me onto a
path to actually get in that place it's
also one of those yeah just I'm indebted
forever to that it was so and I and I
and I also advocate all the time to
people and it's something even if in
theory I did it myself it was just that
I needed something that was very I guess
intellectually stimulating or
challenging or rewarding that that game
is so good at doing that that I feel
like I will carry that with me forever
that's the game that got me through
pneumonia I'm really grateful that I
have the two people that are on this
call that have helped create games that
you guys have truly made games that I
constantly and I'm sure alone is the
same way tell people even if they've
never played a game before this is the
game that you should play Mike I've even
told you this story is like being from
the train from London to Paris playing
Thomas was alone by the time I got off
the train we got into the hotel and I
couldn't shut up about I was like pay me
just need to play this game and she sat
down
tell us his love it's nice I played on
the iPads like you have to play this
game and she instantly she was like he's
just so sad it's like she instantly like
anthropomorphize that's the biggest
trick in Thomas was alone is that like
obviously I'm proud of it in the promo
work we did but at the same time like
it's a game is so much relies on the
empathy you bring to it and it was the
biggest I remember the first prototype I
made had no storytelling no music just
rectangles and all the comments were oh
he's talking about like the yellow one
at that point what didn't even have a
name the one end up being Chris people
saying oh he must be so annoyed that
he's so much littler than the other ones
yeah that's what's so cool about Thomas
is there's so much empathy you bring my
job on that in terms of the writing and
in terms of what we did with the music
and the art was just to stay out of your
imagination so let people bring what
they can to it yeah because yeah you can
force people out of something by forcing
empathy too much they think what's the
material I have no interest in making a
player cry I got to me that's not and
that's not my job like so much to do
with what they bring to it I think it
opened a door and you invite them if
they if they want to walk through it
they can and or just be like have a
response I invite you to have a response
and you may laugh you may cry but it's
the same thing that Neil druckmann sigh
I wanted to I just wanted to be said
that I'm grateful as we like like you
said Austin you a constantly advocate
and and a lot of how you are that you
said you're the champion for this game
it's like um I think it's pretty cool
that we have two people on here that I'm
looking at my screen and and half of the
side our consumers and the other half of
the side are our creators and we're all
creators in our own right but by and
large I've never never made a game have
been a part of making a game but you
guys have have just created games that
were constantly telling people you have
to play this you have to play this so I
think I just think that's really cool
that's what it's worth I feel like to
the extent that that I've made games is
the same extent as you Detroit because I
mike is the true game maker here yeah I
just felt weird about leaving everybody
else out I just have books I just pull
out a book on how to do
I just make what's in the book I think I
think ultimately the if there's one
thing I hope anyone who listen who's
been listening to this podcast and it's
it's lovely actually seeing how much
people enjoy this podcast and and
hearing like from the people who make
games if there's one lesson I hope is
intrinsic to the very format of this
podcast is there are no odors there's no
one person who's responsible for
anything you love we're all ultimately
individuals coming together to make
things and yeah it's very nice of you
guys to say that but ultimately like
Thomas was alone as the result of many
people's work every late census there is
also way more people's work we're all
collaborators game now what how you
market stuff is different as the I I
definitely I mean not above that but
that's a marketing thing right you use a
name I'm a useful proxy when we're
talking about the games and we try and
sell stuff but that's different thing to
the creation of a game and the creation
I would add I would add that even in a
even in a Toby Fox scenario where we're
undertale I'm pretty sure was literally
just him it was I think it was there was
not a single other person involved music
art animation programming design
everything even publishing it was Toby
Fox Terry Fox how he do that
it's crazy it's it's astonishing but I
would add even that there this again I I
risk sounding very pretentious but I
think the collaboration that there's
there is with the players because sure
he had made a game and then never
released it then he is in the most pure
sense an auteur because your game is
nothing without people bringing bringing
their slice into it well so yes it might
be one relationship but it to me it's
like you know in music or live like Troy
talking about stand up last time like
you feel that reaction very viscerally
in the room in the moment but it doesn't
go away just because it's a you
downloaded it through Steam or whatever
and played it at home there's still a
dynamic happening between creator and
performer that is that the game is no
longer this it is everyone's I think
that's something that I really love
about video games is that yeah we all do
bring our own
because games are interactive they let
you be more empathetic than films
generally do because you're in the shoes
of what's happening and I think if a
minute that the game is released and the
world has it they get to put whatever is
happening in their life into it the
witness for me is a very specific thing
that Jonathan Blow never would have
known would happen or would have
occurred to him but that's what that
game is for me that's what I made it
because I was playing through it about
periods when I said it doesn't matter
what he was going for ultimately the
version of the witness exists for you is
the version exists for you it doesn't if
Jonathan Blow showed up tomorrow and
said no alarm oh you've completely
misunderstood my art doesn't matter
which which job and blow probably would
but like that wouldn't affect your
experience right now these are unique
medium and one of the things that makes
me exceptionally passionate about them
is that the minute that they release
everyone brings a piece of them to that
thing no matter who they are they could
not be creative in the slightest and you
will still bring just a history of who
you are as a person to every RPG that
you play into every choice that you make
and then to how you talk about the game
to everyone else as well it's just they
because they're interactive become all
of us and not just the person who made
it which i think is also shadow games
all right I think that should wrap this
I think we can top that
episode I hope you're okay all good
happy to be here
yeah the way the show is weekly so we
will see you guys next Friday
thank you just see how long we keep
going week all right see it
bye guys all right